m
tonight insha allah
we are going to
begin reading in the chapters of zed
and with regards to fasting the month of
ramadan and ertikaf
how the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam used to fast
why the prophet sallallahu alaihi
this is one of the most important
chapters of this book and most pertinent
to us during this time
being that ramadan is swiftly
approaching
we are preparing ourselves
to fast the month of ramadan and it's
one of the pillars of islam
by which a person becomes a full-fledged
member of the muslim
ummah of the muslim nation
that is that islam is built upon five
pillars
as the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
in bukhari a muslim on the authority of
abdullah
islam has been built upon five pillars
the testimony that none is rightfully
worshipped but allah
and that muhammad is his messenger
and the establishment of prayer and
giving zakah
and fasting the month of ramadan
and making pilgrimage to the
house of allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
making hajj for those who have the
ability to do so
this is verbatim the words of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
translated in this narration in bukhari
a muslim
so we see that
fasting the month of ramadan is one of
the pillars
and a pillar is something that
establishes
and is a critical to the integrity of
something
and so when we say that this is a pillar
of
islam it means that it is integral
for a person to meet allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala as a full-fledged
muslim one of his
fulfillments must be participation in
the month of ramadan and i mention here
participation
and i didn't mention fasting necessarily
even though fasting is the predominant
and the default with regards to ramadan
but there are some exceptions
of those individuals who are unable to
fast
which we will discuss inshallah
so fasting the month of ramadan is very
important
and ramadan
is one of the
names of the months of the ninth
lunar calendar year
lunar calendar month of the
lunar calendar year which is the month
of
ramadan this month
of ramadan is a name which was known to
those who were
muslim and those who were non-muslim and
this was its name
prior to islam so before islam
the in jail this month was referred to
as
ramadan and why was it referred to as a
ramadan
it's a difference of opinion amongst the
scholarship of islam
but one of the strong opinions is that
it is named
ramadan taken from the word
is when the sand is extremely extremely
piping hot
and so ramadan would usually fall during
very hot season and
people would often times
fast during this month the month of
ramadan
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
he affirmed
this name the name of the month of
ramadan
and when we look at the names of the mon
in the islamic calendar
we find that there are no names which
are
particular to disbelief
there are no names which are particular
to
gods or goddesses other than allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala
so we have things muharram and
safar
and rabbi al-awwal and rabi athani and
etc none of these names
have an element of shirk in them
none of the names of the 12 months
in islam have any element of disbelief
or haram in them and this is
what their names were before the prophet
sallallahu
alaihi wasallam was appointed as a
prophet
in the time of jehelia their names did
not change just the names of the
weak
did not change why because there is no
references
to anything which is haram or anything
which is
particular to disbelievers
in these in these names so if we look at
the names of the
days of the week we have al ahad which
means one
the first day
which is the second day at
which is the third day of the week
which is the fourth day of the week
which is the fifth day of the week
which is the day of congregating right
we have a sabbath which is taken from al
qatar
and that is because that is the sabbath
that is traditionally the day when the
jews were to respect the sabbath and not
hunt or work or earn during those hours
during that day
and so these days they have nothing that
is particular to non-muslims is
something that is
comes from allah subhanahu wa ta'ala or
some simply a number
contrary to our days of the week
for instance in in english or or the
months
in english most of them root back to
mesopotamian gods and greek mythology
so we look for example at monday which
comes from mano
which is the first day of the week and
we see that monday
is the first day of the week contrary to
islam
in islam the first day of the week is
sunday
then we have tuesday which is the second
and wednesday wednesday
which is a day that predominantly would
be
held for weddings because they viewed
that weddings on this day
is a day that is that is a
a blessed day you get good luck when you
marry
on this day because it's the third day
of the week
likewise we have thursday which is from
thor
which one of the mythical gods of
ancient mesopotamia and
so forth and
saturday which is
dedicated to saturn who is the god of
fertility and the god of the farmers
if you will and then you have sunday
which is the dedicated to the sun
most of these days as we've just heard
are either taken from a language
that is particular to non-muslims or
they are dedicated to
gods that are other than allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
had this been the case in the time of
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
some of these months or days would have
been subject to change
however the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam did not change any of them
because none of the months and none of
the days of the week
were considered to be anything specific
to non-muslims they were all
linguistically linked
rather than having some kind of creedal
undertones
he mentions here
he mentions an entire chapter here which
he dedicates to
how the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
would fast and what fasting is really
about and that's what
this chapter that we're about to read is
about
he mentions that the purpose of fasting
is not to merely deprive oneself of
food and drink he mentions that the real
purpose to fasting is that
an individual
learned to tame himself or herself
from indulging in that which is haram
that which is forbidden this is the real
purpose of
fasting
this is to prepare a person to
be more dutiful to allah
that if an individual fasts that if an
individual
prohibits himself and restrains himself
from things that his body physically
needs
then he can restrain himself from things
that his
his nephs his
the evil part of himself
needs so if he can restrain himself from
that which he naturally needs
he can restrain himself and teach
himself restraint
from that which he unnaturally needs or
feels he needs
he says that fasting prepares the
individual
for paradise and prepares the individual
for complete and utter bliss in the
hereafter
he mentions that when an individual
experiences hunger and when an
individual experiences
thirst that this is something that will
remind the person of those who
experience this unwillingly
meaning the poor people people who do
not have
what we may have at
at our fingertips there are people who
do not have food every night
there are people that do not have clean
water to drink or cold water or pure
water
to drink and so in
fasting when we experience these things
for ourselves
albeit we do it on purpose we do it to
ourselves it's self-induced it's not
something
that is forced upon us
we start to empathize with those who
have
less than us and this is very important
there can be rich people in islam and
there can be very poor people in islam
but they will always be connected in
their
empathy towards one another
islam one of the narratives of islam
is not to make everybody the same to
make everybody rich
or everybody poor that's not correct
it's not a communist religion
however empathy and connectivity
must be maintained between the
rich and the poor always so when the
rich make a mistake the poor
are given as an expiation
this happens often throughout
the poor have a right to portion
of the wealth of the wealthy amongst
their
community members etc
he says another benefit of fasting is
that it
causes the veins and the vessels and the
body to restrict
and this restricts the movement
physical movement of a shaitaan in the
human body
and that is that the prophet salallahu
alaihi wasallam once said
in shaytan
moves through the human being just like
your blood moves through your blood
vessels
and so when a person fasts
it has a physical effect on his body and
it has a spiritual effect on his
soul and his spirit and it will
restrict the movement of a shaitaan
now a person may say well why is it that
it
we are worried about restriction of the
movement of a shaitaan
when the prophet sallallahu alaihi was
said
that when the month of ramadan begins
the devils are chained and yoked
and held back and restrained and that
the doors of paradise are open during
the month of ramadan
why would it be necessary for us then
during the month of ramadan to fast and
why would it be a point that we
restrict the movement and the hold
that a shaitan has on our physical and
spiritual self
and the answer to that is the correct
opinion
of the scholars of islam is that
not all of the
shayateen of the devils are yoked and
chained and kept at bay
during the month of ramadan it's only
maradatus
in another narration the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
added and he said
that the worst of the devils are kept at
bay and yoked
and restrained during the month of
ramadan
but as for your common devil that you
are born with that will stay with you
until the rest of time that will always
whisper to you
evil thoughts and so forth these smaller
devils
which are easier to control easier to
refuse
they are the ones that are not yoked and
chained during the month of ramadan it
is only the most
monstrous of them which are yoked and
chained and kept at bay
during the month of ramadan
now not everything is from a shaitaan
not all evil
comes from a shaitaan if a
shaitaan has a
trained a human being well enough
he might not have to interfere very much
for evil to take place
a person may look around and say well
why is it that evil things happen during
the month of ramadan
war and famine and death and murder and
people do all these terrible things well
that's because
devils come in all forms and there are
devils from amongst humankind as well
and if a person is trained himself
and he has
constantly made a habit of evil
during the month of ramadan it will be
no different
it will just be that that that little
edge is given to the people of piety
that the worst of devils are kept at bay
during the month of ramadan
so a person can proverbial
proverbially catch his breath if you
will
he says so ramadan is
ramadan is the reigns of the people
of of taqwa the rains the rains on
a horse
it helps to bring in that nes and
build that discipline he says and it is
jun
and it is an armor for those who are in
active battle
with a shaitaan and with their nephs and
with it dunya
he says
for those who are most close to allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala and most saintly
fasting is something which is an
exercise to maintain his or her
saintliness
and closeness to allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
then he goes on to mention that fasting
is a very very special type of worship
it's a special type of worship because
it is
only for allah and if a person does it
right
it can only be for allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
it is impossible for fasting to be done
or utilized
as a means to show off right
he's referring to a narration which is
in bukhari a muslim
in which the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
he said all of the actions of the human
being they belong to the human being or
they are for the human being except for
fasting it is for me and me alone and
therefore i
personally will reward
a person fasting
what does this mean well there's a
number of meanings for this that the
scholars of islam have mentioned
the one that ibn al-qaeda mentions here
is that
a person if he truly fasts
then this is indicative that he is doing
it only for the sake of allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
that he believes in allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala it's similar to wudu
there is a narration in which the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
only the believer will
maintain his wudu because it's a secret
it's nobody knows if you have wudu or
not
nobody knows if you have broken your
wudu or not nobody knows if you have
truly made wudu or not
people are unaware you can make wudu in
front of people
and you can break wudu and nobody would
be the wiser
but if you maintain your wudu
in private and in public this
articulates that you believe in a fear
allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
right because only the believer will
truly maintain his wudu
the same thing goes with fasting it's a
secret
i mean i can eat
all that i want to eat fill my belly up
completely and entirely
and then go out into society and none
would be the wiser and i'd say i'm
fasting and everybody would believe me
and take me at my word
as long as i don't eat in front of
people
i can in their eyes be fasting
yet if in private i refrain from those
things which break my fast
just as i do in public this articulates
that this is
only for allah subhanahu wa ta'ala that
this person is doing this
that he believes that allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala is watching him
and so what happens this is personal
between allah subhanahu wa ta'ala and
the servant
it's a very very personal
act of worship between allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala and the servant
and because it is so personal and
because it is a secret
between allah and the servant
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala will maintain
that personal
element to it when he rewards the people
of fasting
so he says
he says fasting is for me and me alone
and i will personally reward the person
who
fasts so allah will not commission
a third party to reward you on his
behalf
an angel or someone of paradise he
personally will take it upon himself the
king himself will
bestow the gift upon you when you meet
him for the act of fasting
he says fasting has
an incredible an incredible
effect on a person's behavior
if a person fasts properly
and incredibly fasting has a very
serious and strong effect
on the human being's spirit
and the human being's inner discipline
and it also has a good physical effect
on the person that it purges the body
you know the the body sometimes we're
constantly eating eating and drinking
and eating and drinking and this process
of digestion and
and disposal and so forth is constant
when a person gives the body a few hours
of reprieve
then this is something that will allow
the body to
regenerate and purge itself so it has
a lot of physical benefits to it
there is a narration that some scholars
of islam view is an authentic narration
one of them being ibn kathir
rahimahullah
[Silence]
he says fast your way to health
meaning if you all fast you will become
healthy
and you know now now people fast
they're just catching up recently we
have this new thing this new thing of
intermittent fasting and you know that's
for the workout freaks and
you know let's do intermittent fasting
and let's fast during this time
in that time and it's so good for the
body and then we have other religions
which fast but they fast in a very
different way
some of them fast by only leaving off
some one
thing that they so let's say they
like
cheez-its so they leave off cheez-its
that's their fasting right
we see this with casa with catholicism a
lot
that a person is too fast he is to leave
off something that he loves or desires
whether that's meat or cheese it or
doritos or whatever it is that's their
form of fasting
there's other form of fasting where some
religions refrain from everything that
is chewed
but anything that you can drink is fair
game so you can drink water and juice
and so forth
none of this has to do with the fasting
of
the muslims the fasting of the muslims
we know there are three things that will
break a person's fast
number one eating or drinking on purpose
purposely remembering knowing that you
are fasting
and consciously breaking your fast by
eating or drinking something
right number two
is sexual intercourse and many scholars
in fact the four
scholars of islam abu
all view that ejaculation
for a person to arouse himself and to
physically ejaculate
or masturbation that this as well
will
cause a person to break his fast they
agree on that
and the third thing that will break a
person's fast
is that an individual intend to break
his fast
that a person intend to break his fast
because the pillars of fasting are
two
you refrain from anything that breaks
your fast
and number two you
have the intention of fasting these
are the two pillars of fasting
the things that will break your fast are
eating or drinking purposefully
as we mentioned before number two
that an individual have sexual
intercourse
or that or ejaculation that is a
physical
one number three
that a woman have her menstruation or
her postpartum bleeding that that
that begin that will break a person's
fast as well
number four that a person
have the intention to break his fast
because that breaks the pillar
of intention you have to have and
maintain
that intention from sunrise until sunset
and as for other things that will break
a person's fast
such as an individual
leading blood bloodletting or
for example pulling a tooth
bleeding things that come
out of the body vomiting
these things will not break a person's
fast only if a person
purposely makes himself vomit if a
person
purposely makes himself vomit this will
break his fast
if not then the person's fast is still
sound as the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
so there are a number of things that
will break a person's fast
and fasting has those two pillars which
are
number one a person must
have the intention to fast number two
they must refrain from anything that
breaks
his or her fast
a lot of times we have questions that
come about
certain things that break a person's
fast during the month of ramadan
anything that nourishes the body by way
of other than
eating or drinking will break a person's
fast
so if i go to the hospital and get an iv
which
basically is food but it's injected
directly into my veins
this would break a person's fast but
if i get the a vaccine
or a shot that is not a shot
that is to take the place or supplement
diet
then this will not break my fast
likewise bleeding will not
break a person's fast in the correct
opinion of the scholars of islam
likewise eye drops will not break a
person's fast
in the correct opinion of the scholars
of islam
suppositories suppositories which is
basically a pill that you know it
instead of taking it orally it
goes up the other end rectally a person
is given a suppository when they have a
very high fever and they have an upset
stomach
this will not break a person's fast
either
so there are a number of things and we
may get into the details of these things
later
but these are some of the things that
often come up a lot
another thing that he mentions
is that fasting is very beneficial when
it comes to taming sexual desire
here he mentions that the prophet
sallallahu
alaihi wasallam commanded that those who
are
unable to get married because they don't
have the means to get married
but they have the desire to get married
and they have the physical desire
that fasting is a widget
a widget meaning it is an armor it is a
defense
and fasting doesn't just mean
that i fast during the daytime and at
night i completely fill my stomach up
that's not what is meant by this
narration of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
this is the narration of ibrahim
in which the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
wording of the narration is the prophet
salallahu alaihi
wasallam
o young men o youth
whoever is able amongst you to marry
then he should do so
for
because getting married will help you to
lower your gaze
and it will help you to tame your
private parts as well
he said and to guard your private parts
he said and whoever has the ability to
marry then he should do so
but whoever amongst you does not have
that ability
then fasting is the best medicine
for that because it is
a protection for him he says
it is a protection against that unwanted
untameable sexual desire
a lot of people misunderstand this
narration and so they fast
and then they say the fasting is not
working no it's working
it's but you have to take the medicine
as it was prescribed
fasting in the arabic language is not
just a person refraining
from food and drink from some from
sunrise to sunset
or from the break of dawn until sunset
what is meant here in the narration is
fasting in a linguistic sense
which means eating a lot less that a
person not
eat to his fill if a person wishes to
tame
his sexual desire one of the best ways
to do this
is that he eat extremely moderately
never fill your stomach up always eat
and continue to make yourself a little
bit hungry even if you're not fasting in
the sense of fasting from morning to
evening that's fine
do that but when you break your fast if
your intention
is to tame your unwanted sexual desires
and unwanted and untamed
unbridled sexual impulses
then you need to do more than that and
that is that you need to
as well eat less
eat less never fill your stomach up
eat less even eat less than a third
of your fill if you are able to do so
continue to make yourself just a little
bit hungry